salut à tous donc aujourd'hui une petite
vidéo particulière c'est plus une vidéo
de récupération d'un objet de recherche
parce que voilà on était empêcha léman
dans le coin on a bloqué sur un truc on
a tiré il nous a semblé sortir du cuivre
voilà c'est un gros objet qui est très
très lourd est vraiment impossible de le
remonter autrement donc là on va aller
voir ce que c'est et on vous reprend ok
ça commence pas super bien je fais dans
l'eau est impossible de remettre la main
sur cet objet la droite non ya un beau
nom mais on n'abandonne pas et elle
cherche comment ça de côté alors
peut-être
[Musique]
ans
un petit moment matt de la terre après
de longues minutes de recherche sous le
regard interrogeaient des passants
je sens quelque chose au niveau de mes
jambes difficile à ce stade d'identifier
l'objet j'y vais doucement pour ne pas
prendre de risques
le cuivre est à nu mais il pourrait
s'agir de câbles électriques souterrains
une petite plongée de peut permettre
d'identifier l'objet
[Musique]
c'est bien ce que nous pensions il
semblerait qu'il sait c'est un gros
câble de cuivre constitué de plusieurs
filtres et si je parviens à détacher à
colombo je retourne sous l'eau pour me
faire une idée plus précise du câble et
de la possibilité éventuelle de le
sortir en entier et mes hommes étaient
au courant qu'on comprend rien à ce que
tu dis ça reste l'auteur des deux côtés
ah oui c'est trop de travail quoi
le câble de cuivre semble être sous
l'eau depuis très longtemps en effet
celui-ci fait une boucle avant de
retourner sous terre par ses deux
extrémités
ou décider au groupe dans un premier
temps de découper cette boucle avec une
pince pour essayer de la sortir en
nature
[Musique]
pour vous montrer ça c'est pas dû faire
les gars ça c'est pas dû faire
jackpot pour savoir comment est ce qu'il
a dans la main là et a peut-être dix
vols de cuivre faut dire qu'on utilise
des peines qui ont été pêchés donc ne
sont pas de meilleure qualité vous
conseille d'acheter vos fins plutôt que
de les pêcher au pire la pêche aliments
la pêche tout coup à la pêche aux
cuivres
nos pains sont définitivement bien trop
ridicule on retombe sur le spot avec une
meilleure pince le coupe boulon fait son
taff et on arrive facilement à sortie
ratée grosse partie du câble de cuivre
[Musique]
on accélère la cadence et on parvient à
sortir de plus en plus de morceaux de
cuivre
[Musique]
à ce moment là on se rend compte qu'il
est possible de décrocher une grosse
partie du câble en tirant sur ses
extrémités et en creusant un pas positif
[Musique]
sam hamad a pas et à travers ce grand
une autre étude
[Musique]
malheureusement nous n'avons pas réussi
à filmer cette scène mais nous avons
continué à tirer sur le câble pendant de
nombreuses minutes jusqu'à en faire
céder partir ok voilà on est rentré et
voilà tout ce qu'on a réussi à ramener
donc toute cette pelote là ici donc un
gros gros câble voilà c'est on n'a pas
réussi à trouver quel type de câble
s'était mais c'est un câble énorme avec
tout le tout le cuivre qui est resté à
l'intérieur
donc voilà il ya plusieurs couches avec
du caoutchouc etc et c'était sûrement en
fait un coin dans lequel les personnes
cachées de cuivre volés parce que voilà
on a on a toute une partie pelote qu'on
a réussi à sortir une partie câble est
aussi un autre câble donc on a sorti en
caoutchouc avec deux de fils de cuivre à
l'intérieur puis voilà ils sont ils ont
rien à voir les deux donc c'était
vraiment un endroit dans lequel la
personne stockées en fait sont son
cuivre volés on n'a pas réussi à
identifier d'où ça peut provenir si
c'était des installations électriques ou
même du chemin de fer ce genre de choses
on n'a pas encore d'infos mais voilà
belle quantité de cuivre en tout cas on
va essayer d'un petit peut désosser ça
même si ça n'a pas l'air facile
il semblerait qu'il a été brûlé aussi vu
l'auteur voilà en général ils brûlent y
brûler les fils pour faire fondre le cas
où tout est et récupérer le cuivre plus
facilement le prix du cuivre est
d'environ 450 kilos là on doit pas
être très loin des 50 kg donc peut être
un petit peu moins c'est faut savoir que
senna des métaux les plus volées en
général donc c'est par des réseaux
organisés qui gère le vol brûlent des
câbles puis ensuite les revendre il
s'attaque à tout type d'installation
mais majoritairement donc des
installations edf sncf
il ya quelques autres industries aussi
bizarrement il y à pas mal de tutoriels
sur youtube sur la façon de brûler du
cuivre même si cette pratique est
désormais interdite
voilà donc on en a certains qui sont
même presque exploser la tête en
essayant de bruit de leurs bien entendu
nous n'allons pas le brûler puisque
voilà on est on est aussi là dans un but
de dépollution des cours d'eau donc on
est c'est pas c'est pas pour faire des
gros feu de caoutchouc à côté on va
essayer de le dénuder à la main voilà
simplement on va voir ce qu'on arrive à
faire
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu en
tout cas pour nous c'était un régal de
la faire c'était du jamais vu aussi
voilà je pense que là la barre est très
haute en terme de trouvailles empêcha
léman n'hésitez pas à nous aider en
commentaire à identifier le type de
câble que c'est parce que voilà on n'a
vraiment pas réussi à trouver et abonnez
vous si vous voulez nous suivre dans nos
prochaines aventures
[Musique]
m